[Musique]
confusion en guinée avec cette tentative
de coup d'état condamné par le
secrétaire général de l'onu le président
alpha condé a été arrêté par les forces
spéciales guinéenne elle dit vouloir
dissoudre les institutions le ministre
de la défense affirme quant à lui avoir
repoussé cette attaque contre la
présidence en toile de fond de ces
tensions de troisième mandat décrié du
président mais pas seulement on en parle
des débuts de cette édition
[Musique]
derniers foyers de résistance en
afghanistan la vallée du panchir serait
en mauvais qui mauvaise posture face aux
talibans ils affirment avoir gagné du
terrain dans ce bastion historiquement
anti-talibans emmenée par le fils du
commandant massoud le cours national de
résistance tente de vous pousser
l'offensive des insurgés désormais au
pouvoir ailleurs dans le pays la vie
semble suivre sous pour gouverner
et puis la syrie prête à aider le liban
à damas par autoriser le passage du gaz
et d'électricité bien son territoire il
s'agit d'enfermer
vivant en plein effondrement économique
et en proie à de graves pénuries
d'énergie une main tendue qui fait suite
à la visite hier d'une importante
délégation libanaise la première en dix
ans
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france
tentative de coup d'état en guinée les
forces spéciales guinéennes ont affirmé
avoir capturé le président alpha condé
un coup de force dénoncé par antonio
guterres est ce le secrétaire général de
l'onu qui demande la libération du
président le ministère de la défense
affirme de son côté que l' attaque des
forces spéciales contre la présidence a
été repoussée ces mêmes forces spéciales
qui ont annoncé la dissolution des
institutions la fermeture des frontières
terrestres et aériennes du pays et vous
allez l'entendre les putschistes affirme
également que la personnalisation de la
vie politique est désormais terminé
nous allons engager une concertation
nationale pour une transition inclusive
et apaisée plus personne à mourir pour
rien
rien ne doit plus mauvais pour la
politique parce que nous avons mis la
politique endurant et d'oublier aussi
ceux qui nous ont la personnalisation de
la politique de la vie politique est
terminée
nous allons plus confie la politique à
un homme nous allons confier au peuple
veut non uniquement pour ça qui a le
devoir d'un soldat décédé le pays
la seule chose qui nous anime c'est ça
nous allons mettre en place et un
système qui n'existe pas et ces systèmes
il faut qu'on le fasse tous ensemble je
pense qu'il est important de se
comprendre déciderez la main et
s'asseoir décrit une constitution qui
est adapté à nos réalités capable de
régler nos problèmes parce que si vous
voyez l'état de nos routes
si vous voyez l'état de nos hôpitaux
vous vous rendez compte qu'après 62
cents s'il est en promo et c'est lui il
faut qu'on s'est levé et pour comprendre
ce qui a pu mener à cette situation en
guinée je vous propose d'écouter
adelkarim yacoub koundougou me chercheur
associé au groupe afrique de lits ps il
revient sur la décision controversée du
président de modifier la constitution
mais aussi sur son 3ème mandat contesté
c'est qu'il faut s'étonner c'est que ce
n'est pas que ces coûts détaillés ou pas
c'est que ça ça dure et notamment c'est
que c'est réussi à dieu jusqu'à
maintenant la situation est tellement
complexe alpha condé en passant par la
force en essayant d'imposer
volonté a réussi à mettre une tension
politique dans ce pays tel qu'il fallait
vraiment s'attendre que ces genres
d'actions s'est produit malheureusement
alpha condé non seulement est passé par
la force ou nous disent y est la
constitution guinéenne alors que la
société civile l'opposition et des
citoyens guinéens se sont mobilisés au
sein du fn d'essayer de front national
pour la défense de la patrie pour
empêcher alpha condé de modifier la
constitution pour pouvoir se présenter
pour un troisième mandat alpha condé
passé il y avait beaucoup d arrestations
ont déjà eu des assassinats ya eu deux
morts ensuite alpha condé est passé en
force par les élections qui a été
contesté par cellou dalein diallo mais
seulement après pour l'apaisement de la
vie politique l'opposition a accepté
pour éviter le bain de sang on va très
bien qu'aujourd'hui la vie revient à la
charge c'est là bas que je fais bien que
cette tension né de l'assentiment de la
constitution ni de l'as passage en force
pendant des élections aujourd'hui la
légitimité de à d'alpha condé a été
contestée sur toute la ligne
situation en afghanistan où les talibans
affirment avoir gagné du terrain dans la
vallée du panchir au pouvoir depuis
maintenant trois semaines ils ont lancé
une offensive pour reprendre ce qui est
le dernier bastion de résistance du pays
la réalité de cette avancée reste
incertaine la vallée du panchir située à
80 km au nord de kaboul et à un
territoire enclavé très difficile
d'accès sur place le fnr front national
de résistance avec à sa tête le fils du
commandant massoud tué par al qaïda en
2001 tentent de repousser les talibans
et alors que la politique talibane est
scrutée de près par la communauté
internationale angela merkel elle prône
le dialogue avec les nouveaux leaders de
l'afghanistan
en ce qui concerne les talibans il faut
évidemment leur parler car c'est avec
eux qu'il faut discuter à présent nous
souhaitons notamment que les personnes
qui ont travaillé pour les organisations
d'aidé humanitaire allemande et qui
aujourd'hui se sentent en danger puisque
aujourd'hui quitter le pays nous
souhaitons également que les
travailleurs des organisations
internationales et l'allemagne les
soutiens beaucoup puissent travailler à
améliorer la situation humanitaire en
afghanistan il y a de la sécheresse les
gens ont faim et l'annoncé hier de la
réouverture de l'aéroport de kaboul est
un signal positif en flic pas la
composition du gouvernement taliban la
haine toujours pas été dévoilée elle
devrait être déterminante pour les
années à venir mais cela non ce ne cesse
d'être reportée en retard qui pourrait
justement s'expliquer par ses combats
qui se déroulent dans la vallée du
panchir ailleurs dans le pays la vie à
elle repris son cours le récit de yamina
benguigui
les monnaies des quatre coins du monde
circule aujourd'hui dans le plus grand
marché de changes d'afghanistan il a
rouvert samedi trois semaines après la
prise de pouvoir des talibans dans un
contexte de crise à kaboul c'est donc
chargé de liasses que les cambistes
négocier avec des centaines de personnes
je suis très heureux que les marchés
aient rouvert récemment tous ont été
affectés par ce que le dollar était à 95
nous importons des biens mais tous les
biens ne sont pas disponibles ici nous
les importants de l'étranger nous les
importants avec des dollars et ici il
nous les vendons avec de l'argent
afghans nous vendons des marchandises et
croyez moi cela a été très affectée au
cours des quinze ou vingt derniers jours
une reprise loin d'être homogènes devant
les banques les files d'attentes
s'allongent les afghans cherchent à
récupérer des liquidités pour faire face
à l'inflation grandissante
l'activité financière est encore au
ralenti même si western union a annoncé
reprendre ses opérations avec le pays
côté éducation les cours ont repris
certains écoliers ont pu retrouver les
bancs de l'école et les enseignantes
leur tableau malgré les contraintes qu
aurait pu leur imposer l'émirat
islamique
pour l'instant la situation est bonne
les femmes peuvent se rendre à leur
travail ici il n'y a pas de problème
avec les classes nous allons continuer à
travailler il n'y a pas de souci il y a
de la sécurité
la charia étant le maître mot dans le
pays depuis l'arrivée des talibans au
pouvoir créer une importante incertitude
dans la reprise des activités de
certains à l'instar de tolo news la
chaîne de télévision nationale qui
continue de diffuser mais dans une
inquiétude ambiante
depuis l'arrivée des talibans beaucoup
de figures de la chaîne ont quitté leurs
fonctions comme le déplore le président
de la maison-mère moby médias ce qui est
triste c'est de perdre autant de
compétences de voir une génération de
personnes dans lesquels nous avions
investi qui aurait pu en faire pour le
pays être obligé de partir il nous
faudra malheureusement encore deux
décennies pour combler cette fuite des
cerveaux alors que les femmes semblent
pouvoir reprendre leur activité plutôt
normalement dans certains secteurs comme
l'éducation ou encore la santé ce n'est
pas le cas dans le journalisme par
exemple selon reporters sans frontières
le nombre de femmes journalistes en
activité à kaboul est passé de 700 l'an
dernier à moins de cent cette année
la situation en afghanistan fait
craindre une nouvelle vague
d'immigration massive c'est pour s'en
prémunir que la turquie accélère la
construction d'un mur tout le long de sa
frontière avec l'iran un sujet qui
divise l'union européenne a créé voir
douce et
la turquie se barricadent entamé en 2010
est pour sécuriser la frontière avec
l'iran la construction de ce mur s'est
nettement accélérée depuis que de
nombreux afghans tentent de fuir leur
pays désormais aux mains des talibans
une barrière de béton qui devrait
s'étaler sur près de 300 km plus de la
moitié a déjà été achevées en conviant
les médias à constater l'avancée des
travaux vendredi ankara envoie un
message clair les réfugiés ne sont pas
les bienvenus en 2016 un accord avait
été conclu entre l'ue et la turquie sur
les migrants venus de syrie en échange
de 6 milliards d'euros les turcs se sont
engagés à accueillir ces réfugiés
4 millions de syriens sont recensés dans
le pays à l'occasion de la réception de
la ministre néerlandaise des affaires
étrangères le chef de la diplomatie
turque a d'ailleurs voulu anticiper
toute nouvelle demande de ce type
émanant de l'union européenne
on n'est pas possible pour les afghans
qui ont été évacués par n'importe quel
pays de rester dans notre pays pendant
une période donnée nous disons depuis le
début que nous n'accepterons pas une
telle offre non pas qu'une telle offre
était est faite par les pays bas
l'union européenne concerné de près par
cette thématique migratoire est divisé
sur la question d'un côté le président
du parlement européen insiste sur la
nécessité collective de prendre ses
responsabilités de l'autre le premier
ministre hongrois viktor orban se montre
à nouveau particulièrement hostile à
l'immigration avec des propos sans
détour
nous ne pouvons pas prétendre que la
question afghane ne nous regarde pas
parce que nous avons participé à cette
mission
nous avons besoin d'une fois forte et
commune sur la scène internationale
l'europe doit prendre ses
responsabilités
cette politique cette approche est
susceptible de détruire l'identité
culturelle de l'europe elle va mener en
europe un grand nombre de personnes non
sécurisés ce qui pourrait engendrer du
terrorisme et de nombreuses difficultés
sociales nous n'avons pas de réponse et
nous ne sommes pas préparés à traiter ce
genre de nouveaux défis
la turquie représente une étape quasi
obligatoire pour les afghans qui
voudraient gagner l'europe reste à
savoir si ankara utilisera cette donnée
comme un moyen stratégique de pressions
diplomatiques au cours de futures
négociations avec bruxelles
c'est la première visite officielle
libanaise à damas en dix ans une
importante délégation de s'est rendu
hier en syrie la série qui offre son
aide à son voisin elle autorise le
transit sur son territoire d'électricité
et de gaz en provenance d'egypte et de
jordanie les etats-unis ont donné leur
feu vert pour cette transaction d'une
urgence vitale pour le liban farah mais
qui
une lueur d'espoir pour le liban ce
samedi et pour la première fois depuis
dix ans la délégation ministérielle
libanaise a rencontré à damas le
ministre syrien des affaires étrangères
fayçal mokdad et le ministre du pétrole
bas santo mais la partie libanaise a
demandé la possibilité d'une assistance
pour le passage du gaz égyptien et de
l'électricité jordanienne via le
territoire syrien la partie syrienne
s'est félicité de notre demande et a
affirmé que la syrie et est prête à la
satisfaire les deux parties se sont
mises d'accord sur le suivi des détails
techniques en mettant en place une
équipe conjointe une équipe conjointe
validé par les états unis
malgré les contraintes de la loi dite
césar adopté en 2019 par le congrès
américain ce texte prévoit de lourdes
sanctions pour un pays en cas de
transaction commerciale avec la syrie
mais fin août
la position américaine sur le sujet
s'est assouplie et pour cause la
situation urgente au liban depuis un an
les libanais font face à l'effondrement
économique de leur pays beyrouth connaît
de graves coupures d'électricité et des
pénuries de carburant qui mettent à mal
ses activités et services les conditions
de vie sont difficiles en raison de la
coupure du courant électrique parfois
nous sommes obligé d'allumer la langue
du téléphone pour pouvoir continuer à
travailler il n'y a ni électricité ni
essence ni mazout
nous sommes trois frères nous
travaillons ensemble nous faisons notre
possible pour aider l'autre à survivre
si je ferme et je reste à la maison d'où
vais-je me procurer l'argent pour
acheter ce dont j'ai besoin pour moi
même et la maison
cet accord entre les deux pays voisins
pourraient sortir la population
libanaise une situation épineuse seul
problème est d'ordre logistique avant de
transférer les importations énergétiques
depuis la jordanie et l'egypte damas
doit être en mesure d'assurer
l'acheminement depuis le début du
conflit dans le pays en 2011 les
infrastructures gazières et électriques
syriennes ont connu d'importants
dommages des travaux nécessaires au bon
transit de carburant qui pourrait
retarder un peu plus encore l'arrivée
d'électricité
devenu une denrée rare dans le pays du
cèdre
une coopération avec la syrie qui n'est
pas forcément vu d'un bon oeil mais qui
est indispensable pour le liban c'est ce
que nous explique françois el bacha
économiste et fondateur de libnanews
aujourd'hui il ya des partis qui sont
toujours très opposés à tout contact
avec la syrie
mais il ya quand même une réalité qui
doit s'imposer aussi parce que on peut
plus continuer comme ça les hôpitaux
manquent de fioul le libanais manque
d'électricité il ya des services qui
sont publiques qui sont menacés
d'effondrement la distribution de l'eau
notamment les hôpitaux toujours avec les
services de réanimation et ainsi de
suite donc c'est parti là
ils se taisent
et la presse locale ne fait pas
tellement
mansion 2 par contre les partis libres
syriens bien sûr salue cette ouverture
et ainsi de suite
l'accès en même temps sur la syrie
permet aussi de rouvrir un accès vers
l'irak et vers le monde arabe donc ça
permet aussi au liban de respirer au top
économiquement si on se contente en
amont beaucoup besoin aujourd'hui
l'actualité en france avec ce huitième
samedi et consécutive de mobilisation
contre le passe à lithaire à travers
tout le territoire hier près de 142
mille protestataires sont descendues
dans la rue selon les autorités c'est
moins que la semaine dernière mais la
détermination des manifestants ne
faiblit pas théo comble
lille et
marseille
[Musique]
toulon
ou encore paris pour ce huitième samedi
de mobilisation ils étaient encore
plusieurs milliers à battre le pavé dans
plus de 200 rassemblements partout en
france
cible de leur vindicte depuis week end
le pass annie terre une mesure perçue
comme une entrave à la liberté pour les
manifestants présents dans les
différents cortèges je pense que là on a
ouvert la boîte de pandore et ce qui
m'inquiète en fait c'est pour ça que je
suis ici c'est surtout l'avenir
par exemple est ce que il faudra un jour
montrer qu'on a un passé sanitaire quand
on veut faire un emprunt bancaire voilà
donc là je trouve qu'on est dans une
dérive qui est très très inquiétant qu
on est pour les 99% des gens qui
seraient unis si on est des gens
pacifistes on veut juste scandé la
liberté
la liberté d'être et choisir tout
simplement je ne suis pas contre le
vaccin pas du tout mais que se vacciner
respecte les non vaccinés donc c'est la
liberté qui doit primer voilà et
j'aimerais bien que liberté fraternité
égalité heureux sont soit correspondent
à quelque chose aujourd'hui
particulièrement attendu le chiffre de
la participation pour cette première
mobilisation depuis la rentrée de
septembre n'a pas que lui le rebond
attendu selon les chiffres du ministère
de l'intérieur les cortèges sont loin
d'avoir rassemblé autant de monde qu'au
coeur de l'été où le mouvement avait
rassemblé jusqu'à deux cent trente sept
mille personnes face à la multiplication
des personnes vaccinées près de 50
millions de français désormais
l'opposition peine à trouver le soutien
de l'opinion publique selon un dernier
sondage
67% des personnes interrogées approuvent
le pass and i ter pas découragé les
organisateurs appellent à une
mobilisation massive le 11 septembre
prochain en attendant la grève générale
prévue le 5 octobre à laquelle il espère
joindre leurs revendications
[Applaudissements]
à huit mois de l'élection présidentielle
emmanuel macron a fait cette semaine sa
rentrée politique à marseille une visite
de trois jours dans la cité phocéenne où
de laquelle le chef de l'état a
notamment présenté un plan d'urgence
pour la ville un milliard et demi
d'euros de financement pour les
transports le mal logement ou encore la
sécurité en ligne de mire de ce
déplacement la jeunesse et la pauvreté
pour tenter de mettre un terme à un
quotidien de plus en plus difficile pour
certains marseillais david khalifa et
sébastien duffo
inqualifiable
comme un sentiment d'abandon de vide
la cité félix-pyat tu dans le 3e
arrondissement de marseille symbolise
tous les maux d'une ville meurtrie par
l'insalubrité est criante des logements
vivre dans ces conditions frôle
l'indécence mais c'est pourtant une
réalité pour des milliers d'habitants
marché c'est sale c'est ça on est mal à
loger on est mal on est mal un mail
envoyé aider des gens qui c'est à dire
comme quoi un nouvel les toilettes et
les salles de bains mais c'est un
travail bidon c'est mal fait on est on
est rien on irait à la réalité
incroyable même son cloche pour une
partie de la jeunesse envisager un
avenir est compliquée voire impossible
ils nous ont mis les travaux ils sont
fait maintenant mes frères les travaux
ça date pas de maintenant il faut les
faire ça date depuis 2010 de plus belle
avant après je sais pas si vous avez
déjà visité les appartements du ces mais
ces deux bâtiments délabrés la plupart
puits d'eau
[Musique]
il faut pour venir en aide à ces jeunes
éviter qu'il ne tombe dans le trafic de
drogue véritable fléau qui a fait
sombrer certains quartiers dans l'ultra
violence de nombreuses associations ont
été créées c'est le cas de familles en
action dans ses locaux de nombreux
jeunes se réunissent crée des liens
passent leur permis on du rattrapage
scolaire mais avec une si petite
structure seuls quelques dizaines
d'adolescents peuvent bénéficier de
cette aide l'urgence est bien de
développer au maximum ses locaux mais le
manque de moyens est criant
d'autant plus que le gouvernement a
considérablement baissé son budget
associatif depuis la prise de fonction
des manuels macron notamment au niveau
des subventions ces dernières ne
représentent en plus en 2010 est que 20%
des ressources selon une enquête sur le
paysage associatif français dimitri
personnes fondateur de cette association
espère donc que la venue d' emmanuel
macron n'est pas simplement de la poudre
aux yeux tant que marseillais est ce que
c'est un coup de pub là pour la fin des
passes pour sa future réélection ou est
ce que c'est vraiment en prenant compte
vraiment des gros aléas à ce qu' il faut
attendre qu'il y ait des morts pour voir
qu'on puisse se réveiller et prendre
conscience de la chose dramatique qui se
joue en profondeur adam marseille dans
tous les cas oui bien sûr qu on dit
merci et il faut mais après c'est de se
dire ce matin j'écoutais des
informations c'est de se dire c'est bien
investir mais c'est bien aussi je pense
qu'il ya une contrôle des finances ne
pas attendre qu'il y ait des morts pour
réagir s'investir de manière durable
pour la ville d souhait que partage
oussama mohammed lui aussi faisait
partie de cette association lorsqu'il
était plus jeune il est maintenant
éducateurs et prend conscience
aujourd'hui des réalités électorales des
choses concrètes pour les jeunes et nous
c'est ça en fait parce qu'il ya deux ans
j'étais jeune on va dire je croyais à
haskell à dire là le dire qu'il a dit
qu'il allait nous venir nous visiter
tout ça et on attend ça on attend de
voir et on veut qu'ils voilà la réalité
du doubs ce secteur on les voit pas
forcément les élus on les voit que que
les ponts dans les élections pendant les
choses comme ça quand ils ont besoin de
nous mais après nous on a l'impression
que quand on a besoin d'eux
marseille fait face à des défis cruciaux
concernant la jeunesse et l'habitat
indigne emmanuel macron le sait ces
engagements ne doivent pas rester des
promesses sans lendemain il sera attendu
au tournant si toutes ces paroles ne
sont pas concrétisées
l'actualité de la semaine marquée
également par la tenue du forum
économique orientale à vladivostok un
sommet consacré cette année aux
opportunités pour l'extrême-orient
plusieurs expositions se tenait en marge
de cette rencontre l'occasion de
s'intéresser à l'extrême orient russe
notre correspondante verhaeghe hoffman
nous présente les différentes régions
qui composent ce territoire mais aussi
de les richesses que l'on peut trouver
amélioration du climat d'investissement
dans l'extrême orient russe a été un des
sujets principaux de ce forum économique
orientale j'ai décidé de faire le tour
de l'exposition pour voir justement où
l'on peut investir dans sept régions
russes
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la région de
transbaïkalie une terre extrêmement
riche en ressources naturelles vous y
trouvez du fer du charbon de l'or de
cuivre d'ailleurs sans gisement de
cuivre est le plus grand en russie mais
pas mal aussi d'opportunités d'investir
dans le secteur d'agriculture
[Musique]
bienvenue au kamtchatka une des régions
les plus pittoresques russe pas mal de
possibilités d'investir ici les projets
d'infrastructures à la sphère sociale
mais aussi les projets touristiques il
paraît que les spots de surf etc sont
les meilleurs au monde et si
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans la région du magasin le
leader russe en extraction de l'or et de
l'argent l'année dernière par exemple
ils ont extrait presque 50 tonnes d'or
et 572 tonnes d'argent nous on va aussi
essayer de trouver en dehors ici que le
stand
bon j'imagine les spectateurs d'ayrté
france ont déjà l'avé lors plusieurs
fois dans leur vie donc ne critiquez pas
trop ma technique je vais essayer de
trouver un petit lingot d'or ici
et voilà
[Musique]
les chants chamanique sont extrêmement
puissants c'est bien connu il ne serait
pas étonnant qu'ils attirent les
investissements
[Musique]
le reste de l'actualité internationale
en bref et en images
en afrique du sud l'ex président jacob
zuma est remis en liberté provisoire
pour des raisons médicales selon un
responsable l'ancien chef d'état avait
subi une intervention chirurgicale au
début de son emprisonnement d'autres
opérations avaient été annoncées par les
autorités pénitentiaires accusé d'
outrage à magistrat il a été condamné à
15 mois de prison jacob zuma avait déjà
été envoyé en observation dans un
hôpital extérieur a si l'on s'irrite
dernier quelques jours avant le début de
son procès pour corruption
nabil karoui ancien candidat à
l'élection présidentielle tunisienne
placé en détention provisoire en algérie
il est poursuivi avec son frère pour
entrée illégale sur le territoire il
avait été arrêté fin août par la police
aux frontières dans le nord-est du pays
après un avis de recherche lancés contre
eux nabil karoui est poursuivi depuis et
2017 dans le cadre d'une affaire de
blanchiment d'argent et de fraude
fiscale
ils disent non à la nouvelle loi
agricole des milliers d'agriculteurs se
sont rassemblées aujourd'hui dans le
nord de l'inde pour manifester contre le
projet de loi visant selon eux à
détruire leurs moyens de subsistance
ils ont réaffirmé qu'ils poursuivraient
leurs six teams le long des principales
autoroutes menant à new delhi jusqu'à ce
que la législation soit abrogée pour
rappel les agriculteurs quant aux
frontières de la ville depuis fin
novembre
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à vous d'avoir suivi vous trouve
dans une trentaine de minutes pour un
nouveau journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
parce qu'à une période de stabilité en
haïti est ce que ça a été est ce que ça
existe et je la fais plus de cent ans
que l'on avait assisté à l'assassinât
d'un président à un public averti l'état
de droit a été véritablement mis à mal
pour permettre l'assassinât sur un mode
crapuleux l'on a vu en fait se
constituer des armées privées qui
aujourd'hui ont totalement perdu le
contrôle de leur trou et lorsque ces
gangsters sont recrutés par des hommes
politiques ça vous donne